We wondered if it would happen a and it's
starting to happen. Secretary of state, Mike
Pompeo says that state department officials
are going to be ignoring impeachment depositions
for which they were scheduled to appear. Now
an important note, there has been some confusion
about this.
They were not subpoenaed. They were not yet
subpoenaed. Maybe it would be the way to say
it. A Trump lawyer, Rudy Giuliani had documents
subpoenaed. I told you about that yesterday.
We don't know if he's going to comply. Palm
PEO is doing something different. These are
requests to appear and Palm PEO, the secretary
of state has directed state department officials
not to show up to these hearings as part of
the Donald Trump impeachment inquiry. And
this is sort of the first shot across the
bow. They aren't yet ignoring subpoenas, but
they are certainly saying we're not going
to comply easily. So this is an ethical escalation
and the question is one of what happens next.
The context here is that secretary of state
Palm PEO is every, I want to say with every
day with every passing few hours. Palm PEO
is a bigger and bigger player in the entire
Ukraine scandal we learned in the last day
or two that Palm PEO was on the live call
that Donald Trump had with the Ukrainian president
that is at the heart of everything that is
going on right now.
The whistleblower report, the impeachment
inquiry, et cetera. So that pulls Palm PEO
in further and he and William Barr at some
point should to testify about their involvement.
Here's the situation, bigger picture as I
see it, the walls are closing in on these
people, all of them. Uh, they're flouting
the rule of law. They've been doing it for
years at this point in time. They are realizing
some of them without the help of attorneys
and maybe some with the help of attorneys
that they're their best way out is simply
not to participate. Now why would they have
that idea? Because ignoring subpoenas and
not participating and not showing up and not
talking to people so far has worked pretty
damn well for the president of the United
States and lots of the people around him.
So ultimately they are putting the onus back
on us who are investigating them.
Will they be forced into compliance by Democrats
or will they be allowed to ignore the legitimacy
of co-equal branches of government? If you
turn on right wing radio or Fox news or whatever,
you will hear the following storyline. Democrats
are waging a ACOU to illegally remove Donald
Trump from office. That's the story they are
telling. It's a bogus story. The real coup
that is being attempted is the usurping of
checks and balances and co-equal equal branches
of government by the Trump administration,
breaking the law and then breaking it again
to avoid facing the law. And now if and until
they issue subpoenas and if, until those subpoenas
are ignored, nobody can even be held in content,
be a contempt because these are not yet subpoenas.
And so far there is no sign that they are
going to show up when requested. We have Rudy's
documents subpoenaed, but these state department,
um, uh, requests are just that they're just
requests to appear and they need to now subpoena
these people before they can even potentially
hold them in contempt of Congress.
But that will be a big moment if indeed it
ever happens. History tells us, and what I
mean is the last two and a half years, the
last two and a half years of history tells
us that they will ignore the subpoenas the
house subpoenaed William Barr for failing
to provide that unredacted copy of the Mueller
report bar ignored it hasn't suffered any
consequences. In fact, he's right in the middle
of this entire Ukraine fiasco from which he
should be recused the house subpoenaed treasury
secretary, Steven [inaudible] for a Donald
Trump's taxes. It was ignored. There were
no consequences. I could go on. The difference
is that in an impeachment inquiry, it's possible
that the enforcement of the subpoenas would
be expedited in a court dispute. The downside
is with every passing week, more and more
of the people that are on the courts, our
judges and justices that have been appointed
by Donald Trump himself, but when it gets
down to it, when the rubber meets the road,
Democrats are either going to have to hold
someone accountable or not and if not, this
entire impeachment inquiry is pointless unless
you actually enforce your powers.
There's the, the sort of top level conversation
has been well is going to serve to actually
have the Senate convict Trump and remove him
from office. I think that's the wrong conversation.
I've told you from the beginning, I don't
even think it's on the table that that is
possibly going to happen. The real question
is are you even going to get a proper full
and a deep inquiry if everybody ignores your
subpoenas for documents, if everybody ignores
your requests to appear and potentially subpoenas
to appear. If we, if we get to that point,
what are we going to get out of it? We're
going to get nothing. So I hope that Democrats
have a strategy around this. I hope that someone
is going to be ready to at least attempt to
enforce their constitutional power and remember
when I've been actually checking out some
right wing radio recently and right wing TV
just to see what they're saying.
They are pulling this idea out of their hat
or it's coming out of the woodwork that the
inquiry is an attempt at a coup. Remember
these are coequal branches of government.
They are supposed to based on what the framers
wanted and the way our system was designed,
they are supposed to comply with the supervisory
and investigative capacity and duties of the
house of representatives. The COO would be
flouting the law and then flouting all attempts
that are legal and constitutional to explore
what was done previously. I hope they don't
allow it to happen, but a a co, you know,
some people get mad when I'm too pessimistic.
We've not seen evidence that Democrats are
going to actually enforce the coequal branch
of government status that they are supposed
to have in these impeachment inquiries. I
hope that they do. We'll see if anybody shows
up. We'll see if Rudy's documents ever, ever
turn up. Make sure you are following the David
Pakman show on Instagram at [inaudible].
David Pakman show. Lots of great stuff happening
there. And while you're on your phone looking
at Instagram, follow me as
well
at [inaudible] dot package